thanks to brilliant for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
go to brilliant.org microcosmos to get
20
off an annual premium subscription
some of the ciliates we find in the
micro cosmos
have a sort of stoutness to them like
the declarative trumpet shape of the
stenter
or the oblong of the paramecium
but then you have this little weird
fellow which looks more like a twisty
slithering worm
than a unicellular organism this
is a trichello cersid and no i do not
know if i'm pronouncing that
entirely correctly it's a member of a
class of associates
called the karyo relictia we'll be
showing you a few different trichello
cersei's today
though we can't specify their genera any
further without using other experimental
and microscopy techniques to see the
smaller structures inside them what they
all have in common though
is that they come from a place that we
have not really visited yet
on our journey through the microcosmos
they come
from the beach james our master of
microscopes
hired two phd students to help him with
a very important task
every month they bring him wet sand from
the sea
yeah maybe some of us might get a
subscription box filled with items
related to our favorite hobby
james gets a monthly subscription of
sand
and not just a little bit of sand hearer
there he gets
leaders and leaders of it that he then
sifts through
to find the microbes living inside
they're tucked away in the space between
the grains of sand in pockets of water
called
interstitial water and while for many of
us a day at the beach might sound like a
nice relaxing vacation
things are very different for the
microbes who live there
those little bits of interstitial water
are a chaotic habitat
just imagine your life at that scale
surrounded
by sharp pieces of sand that to you
probably
would look more like giant boulders but
imagine
that those rocks aren't just gigantic
they're moving in a constantly shifting
landscape of sedimentary
rubble a cutting maze that's always
changing
as waves crash upon you to survive
you can't just rely on adapting in the
moment you have to rely
on countless generations of adaptation
and evolution
that have made it possible for you to
respond and survive in
the world around you and for the karyo
relicteds evolution has provided them
with a number of tools to handle
their tumultuous surroundings
most cario electeds live in the sands of
marine environments
the notable exception are species of
luxoties which live in fresh water
you've probably noticed that the
trichlos surcid while very worm-like
still has some of its own distinct
shapes if we were asked to compare it to
another ciliate we might look at the
lacrimaria olor with its neck
similarly extending and seeking and
retracting
and like the lacrimaria the focus of the
carrier relicted's pursuit
is probably food they particularly enjoy
a diet of
other organisms like bacteria diatoms
and even rotifers
but the cario relictia doesn't just get
to focus on hunting
in a world that is always changing the
ability for the karyorelikia to
twist and turn their elongated body
helps them navigate their uncertain
terrain and the narrow corridors that
fill it
it also helps that some species can grow
as
large as five millimeters
long karyorelictids can also use their
cilia to attach themselves
two grains of sand giving themselves
something to anchor onto if needed but
even then
a little bit of damage seems inevitable
i mean this is
sand and waves that can hurt even when
you're
not a microbe but the karyo relicteds
they have a solid backup plan
regeneration it's a classic amongst
microbes
you cut one piece and the organism grows
that piece back
stitching itself anew in the case of the
cario relictia
some species can regrow parts of their
body within
three or four hours
a lot of the traits we're describing in
the keryolectids are traits shared by
other ciliates
that live in their own environments but
just refined through generation
upon generation of interstitial life but
there is something that's a bit
more unusual their nucleus doesn't
divide
like other ciliates the carrier electeds
have
macronuclear and micronuclei sometimes
multiples of them the macronuclei
provide the genetic template for the
cell's day-to-day life
while the micronuclei provides the
genetic material that will be used and
passed on during sexual reproduction
we talked about this process more in our
recent conjugation episode if you're
curious
how that works and for most ciliates
when the organism divides
the macronucleus divides with it
ensuring that the new daughter cells
each have their own macronucleus but
this is not the case
for the carrier relicteds when they
divide their macronuclei
don't so the daughter cells use their
micronuclei to make a whole
new macronuclei karyo relicteds are
usually observed with
multiple macronuclei which is probably a
way to ensure that
there's at least some functional nucleus
around while the organism is making a
new one
it's not clear what this strange
macronuclei behavior and its
specificity to karyorelictids says
about these organisms and their
evolution to some scientists it means
that maybe
carrier electeds mirror some kind of
ancestral
ciliate state of nucleus non-division
while others
consider it a potential evolutionary
add-on
that helps offset mutational damage in
the organism
one of the challenges of being able to
study their nuclei is the fact that most
carrier-related species
have been difficult to cultivate in the
lab there's something
a little frustrating but also very true
to our attempt to understand biology
that these organisms
are so difficult to house in the
well-fed comfort of a flask
and yet thrive in the harsh reality
that makes them so fascinating to begin
with
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you to
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
brilliant has courses about science
engineering computer science and math
and while we may not be fighting to
survive between giant grains of sand
as waves of water crash down around us
we are constantly experiencing other
forms of
waves in our everyday life right now for
example as you are
listening to this video sound waves are
coming out of your speakers or
headphones
and it may be hard to think of those
waves in the same way that you think
about waves on a sandy shore
but with courses like waves and light on
brilliant
you can learn what sound and water waves
have in common
you'll learn basics like what a wave
actually is
how they travel and by the end you'll
have a greater understanding of how
waves work in relation to everything
from noise cancelling headphones
to earthquakes it's a wonderful way to
develop a more robust understanding of
how
our universe works the courses are
designed to be hands-on with interactive
quizzes
and guided problems with explanations if
you're interested in learning more
you can get 20 off an annual premium
subscription at brilliant.org
microcosmos the people you're seeing on
the screen right now
are our patreon patrons they are the
people who make journey to the micro
cosmos possible
so thank you so much to all of them if
you want to learn how to become one of
those people you can go to patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram
and if you want to see more from our
youtube channel there's always a
subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you